some people have no shortage of options
when it comes to a career the son of a
Doctor Alan Henderson considered
medicine but you may know his name
because of the different path he took
star basketball player with four NBA
teams now he's moved on to a whole new
Pursuit creating a line of Liquors that
honors some pioneers of the past
we're just going to basically Center
that up at the dry Hills Distillery Alan
Henderson and Jeff drog are tapping into
a time-tested tradition
finding the right blend aged at the
right time to create the perfect taste
this is our birdie Brown straight weed
whiskey here
Henderson asked Rogue to help him Barrel
a brew and come up with a recipe to pay
homage to Montana Moonshiner
birdie Brown
oh wow it bites at the beginning
and at the end too nice spice you know I
just look at her as just being really
just the ultimate boss in an unexpected
place at an unexpected time
Dry Hill sits in the heart of Bozeman
about three hours south from where
birdie Brown settled as a homesteader
out of the 1.6 million people granted
land to Homestead in the mid-1800s less
than one percent were African-American
and she ended up growing her own grains
she destroyed her own liquor had her own
little parlor where she would sell her
product out and she was doing all this
by herself during prohibition during
prohibition it was just
an amazing story to me and I have to say
growing up I didn't think about people
look like me homesteading Henderson has
branded her story and others like St
Louis Spirit Master Tom Bullock who in
1917 became the first known
African-American to publish a cocktail
manual in Tom's book he's got your 170
recipes whatever I went through every
recipe titled the ideal bartender I
would go into liquor store and I
wouldn't see any bottles that looked
like me or were telling stories that
really spoke to me
we began in Indianapolis the son of a
physician he was playing in college
basketball with plans to go to medical
school until the NBA Came Calling in 12
years he was a star forward on four pro
teams yes it definitely is my second
career my first love I fulfilled was
playing basketball and I was able to do
that at the highest level then when I
got to Atlanta the music scene was
burgeoning we ended up doing an
independent music company sold a hundred
thousand records and I was always
dabbling in something so you own a few
smoothie Kings yeah we did we had some
some of those restaurants going and I
was always just curious about things and
curious about business what is who So
the plan who's to me is just an unaged
whiskey but we're not allowed by legal
reasons to say unaids Whiskey on it
because to be a whiskey it has to touch
a barrel and this hasn't touched the
barrel at all we put that straight into
the bottle at 100 Proof Henderson says
his Hooch is close to Birdie's original
which was revolutionary for its time but
it's difficult to produce because it can
kill you and she evidently did it with
some Panache yes with some Panache and
she was known for having great great
tasting Spears that were safe like you
said which was a which was a big deal
you know I've never seen whiskey that
was clear before it's very smooth
because we use the wheat oat and barley
it's different than like a corn
moonshine or straight uh unased whiskey
you may see so it's very smooth even
though it's 100 proof a lot of people
use it in place of vodka adds a little
elevated experience
no Barrel action
oh
what a cat it's not just his brand he
hopes to push forward but the industry
as a whole so our mission is to
diversify the bar I feel like with these
huge companies these Global
conglomerates the space for us to launch
Brands there's space for us to be
distillers places for us to be in
marketing and sales and distributing
Henderson Spirits is among a growing
class of spirit makers changing the game
evolving from Big industry brands
bolstered by celebrity names to those
self-made startups everything we know
about something changes six-year-old
Uncle nearest is the fastest growing
bourbon in U.S history distilling
independently in Shelbyville Tennessee
under the watchful eye of Fawn Weaver
fawn's just done an outstanding job
telling a great story having a great
product we are here to make the pie
bigger and also now championing other
brands helping other brands come up and
give them a chance it's really neat to
see and I think it's that that Spirit of
helping one another because it's a I
think it's a 37 billion dollar industry
so there's room for all of us to play
it's not like if I win you can't win
it's not like that I think there's room
for all of us to see see good success
they have everything they need to make
this great liquid we have the still the
fermenters the Mashers right here it's
hot yeah it's hot who decide Henderson
sees opportunity ahead to reverse the
Erasure of pioneers both past and
present there's a big discrepancy not
just in spirits but just across all
businesses with the with the way the
investment comes in as far as it
accessing yeah access to Capital life
for companies like ours we want to grow
we want to build a buy more barrels we
want to you know go from hundreds to
thousands to tens of thousands of
barrels and we want to get there as we
look for investment we're learning it's
a little it's a little bit different so
I'm really excited about this year for
us and I'm hoping I can be somebody that
helps raise that percentage of funding
that comes towards minority companies
and that success comes one shot glass
have another sip let's have another sip
at a time
here's the birdie Brown I'm all about
the hooch
can you tell I liked it yeah you didn't
think we could handle it I know I wanted
to drink down a little bit here is some
simple syrup and some cheers your
reaction was cheers yeah no it was but
you know what's so great these stories
coming out about our story past it
really link us in so many ways Tom
Bullock who wrote that book the ideal
bartender
he got help from our 41 our 44 41st
president's great-grandfather that would
be
George Herbert Walker Bush yes
he got help he worked at uh he worked at
a country club and so that's that was a
mess yes but allyship is wonderful and
that's kind of what you're seeing
throughout the spirit industry right now
people helping one another to succeed
and and that's what everyone is very
excited the drink is lovely but in the
breakers
[Music]
the drink's lovely it's it's it's
a lot